and while we're on the topic of election
lies let's talk about Lynn wood for a
moment the uh trump-loving lawyer
recently got smacked down in an
embarrassing Way by yet another Court
over his bogus election fraud claims
now Linwood
I'm sorry he's such a comical character
if he weren't so you know obviously
whatever but anyway Linwood goes out
December of last year files multiple
different lawsuits alleging fraud but
the main ones he filed were in the state
of Georgia where he had two separate
lawsuits going one challenging the
results of Georgia's uh presidential
election the other one actually came a
little later in January challenging the
senate election and in that challenge
which the first one the election
challenge in general was thrown out uh
said it was baseless the other one got
thrown out for a second time by the
court of appeals late last week because
they said that Linwood you have no
standing in this case
so here's what Lynn wood was actually
challenging here wood came out and said
that because they changed the rules the
state changed the rules for signature
verification the whole thing is
fraudulent and you cannot trust it they
didn't have the same
um
signature verification
for the absentee ballots that were
obviously very prevalent in that Georgia
runoff election so
the first court that looked at this way
way back in early this year
said yeah you don't have standing to say
any of this
the state legislature controlled by
Republicans passed a law that gave their
Republican Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger the ability to change the
rules for the absentee ballots because
it was in the middle of a pandemic they
knew they were going to have a lot of
absentee ballots they were counting on
it that is what their election was
basically going to have to be because of
the pandemic he had the authority to do
this The Authority given to him by the
state
you therefore have no standing Linwood
and the court of appeals last week
basically told him the exact same thing
you have no injury you have no actual
claim of illegal activity again because
he was given the authority to do this
States as we all know have the authority
to determine how their own elections are
run without the interference of outside
forces so no Mr wood you don't get to
come into these courts and tell us that
something illegal happened when all of
the changes that you're actually
challenging were approved by the state
no injury no illegal activity no
standing for Mr Lynn wood
um I don't know how many total Court
losses this brings us to at this point
with people like Linwood and Giuliani
and Sydney Powell but I can promise you
they're going to continue to lose
but of course that hasn't stopped the
Republicans in all these states where
the lawsuits are losing from enacting
these highly uh oppressive and
repressive voting laws
so that I guess is the silver lining for
Republicans you may be losing the court
battles but you've won the war on voter
suppression for now
we have to take a quick break I'm Farren
cousins from Ring of Fire sitting in for
David packman we'll be right back
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
dedicated to documentaries I Can't Get
Enough documentaries if you're the same
way you really should sign up for
curiosity stream which has a better
selection of docs than Netflix Hulu or
Amazon I'm always finding documentaries
on curiositystream I can't find anywhere
else I recently watched David
attenborough's light on Earth just
fantastic but they have something for
everybody politics economics history
technology psychology everything in
between I can watch at home on my TV in
my living room I can watch on my phone
if I'm on the go I love documentaries
and if you do don't waste your time on
other streaming services once you get
curiosity stream you will regret that
you didn't do it sooner when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman you'll save
25 off of a subscription that will make
it just 15 bucks a year the link is
right underneath this video